Cicero talks about friendships and he is
very concerned with the virtues and we
can call this types of goodness in a
friend and one thing has to do with with
the nature of genuine friendship yeah
you know so got this diagram sort of
sketched out not particularly pretty on
the board but did you get the idea for
genuine friendships can you have a lot
of those in your life Cicero doesn't
think you can because because you you
don't have to actually test some of
these character for quite a while and
you know really good people are hard to
find anyway I think you've experienced
this up to this point there's a lot of
people you think are good or who would
like to think that they're good but it
turns out when you actually put them to
the test they're not right maybe you're
yourself you realize that you fail in
certain respects you think you're a
better person than you are and then you
get thrown into tough situations where
you need to do something for the friend
and it turns out you're not a good
friend and you can change that but it's
good to know that so genuine friendships
are fairly rare and they're kind of at
the pinnacle there they're higher
they're more valuable than other kinds
of relationships and then you've got
like a whole broad base of friendships
that are based on other factors like you
know being useful so you know what are
useful things that friends do for each
other
invite each other to the parties give
each other rides you know I think you
can think of lots of examples trade each
other you know lecture notes you help
each other out in classes I mean what
are other things you do that are useful
dude you ever cook for your friends or
your friends cook for you
sometimes I suppose you could say
trading off buying meals you know you go
out with your friends I'm going to get
the tab this time
that's that's usefulness right but there
are the ways your friends are useful
like you know a few like dating a lot
and then picking people up and you have
you know if they call a wingman
alright suppose wingwoman and be the
opposite that would be a useful friend
right they're useful for picking up
people at the wherever you pick them up
the bar the supermarket weird places
though there's pleasure you know
we enjoy a lot of people's company and
we like hanging out with our friends and
we get to know people over time because
we do activities that we enjoy together
you know don't take a class well let's
say you have an interest in cooking but
the culinary they have all these forget
exactly what they call them used to be
continuing ed classes now they're called
something different if you want to take
if you're really interested in sausage
making you've always wanted to know how
to make sausages they have a whole class
on that and you go up there and hang out
with some other people who are really
into sausage have a good time together
so long as you get a talking sausage
your friends right sports things are
like that I think music is like that
you know you go to a concert if you go
to a concert and you don't like
everybody there at the concert you just
look at them like you know scum that you
know are in your way and you're missing
the band you're kind of missing out on
the concert going experience right
because what's fun about going to a
concert
you get to be there with a lot of other
people who are as into that band as as
you are well it's not quite the same for
classical beers before everybody sits
down you know it's something kind of or
you know sports right watching the game
with your friends that's pleasurable
isn't it you probably wouldn't die for
them and here's where Cicero's getting
where do we go wrong mixing these things
up we saw this with Aristotle but it's
important to to be able to distinguish
between the different kinds of
friendship and with Cicero this is very
tied in with living a good life having
self-knowledge understanding who you are
the kind of person that you are would
like to be it's very important to be
able to actually look at things in a
realistic manner and say this is a
person who's just an acquaintance I
don't have to call them you know my
close friend I don't have to feel under
pressure to invite them over all the
time that that's okay according to
system and being unrealistic is what
gets us in trouble
gets us in trouble with respect to what
we do for ourselves what we put up with
from other people and what we do to
other people then there's this question
about then where does family fit in
that's a good question Cicero doesn't
completely resolve that he holds out the
possibility that you might have family
that you're stuck with that you don't
like at least at this point in time you
know if goodwill is lacking he says
you're kindred or just you know kindred
they're not they're not really friends
but family is something a little bit
different than you know these
friendships based on utility or pleasure
because you're pretty much stuck with
your family your mom and dad are gonna
be your mom and dad your whole life
whether you like it or not and
conversely you're their kid whether they
like it or not you could be friends or
you could not but you know if if you
quit being useful or pleasurable to each
other it's not like you're gonna break
up with mom yeah you people say stuff
like that in dramatic ways but that
doesn't really happen that long does it
so families will you know kind of a
different thing in here but it but it
could fit into either it's could you
have a really good relationship with
your siblings which maybe you don't have
at this time maybe maybe you think that
you do but you know you haven't really
put it to the test and then you know
when you're 40 years old you'll realize
that you you actually are really close
with your brother or sister
because you admire their character which
now you've gotten to know and you'd have
to have some of this in year two in
order to be able to to recognize that so
this is all just sort of read yeah let's
talk now about that virgin at goodness
so I should have actually put this
question yeah what goes into making a
person a good person in our culture
what are what are traits that you like
doing helpful things okay so being
willing to respond when there's needs
things in the Lord oh okay so that's a
big one now I'm not doing it just to get
something else out of the other person
not reducing it to usefulness like you
know I if I do something nice for you as
a professor right I make sure to give
you a feedback so that my student
evaluations will look really good at the
end of the semester you can tell this is
the professors who like aiming for
evaluations because I think bring in you
know something to eat on the day of the
evaluation and something to drink
we often say I scratch your back you
scratch mine so I scratch your back
without any worry that you're gonna
scratch mine that's a good trait that's
left being generous right we call it
generosity real generosity doesn't
doesn't count the cost what else that
doesn't that is an admirable trait
yeah yeah and you notice that Cicero
places at front and center in friendship
by the way that that Aristotle did and
Plato
being willing to tell each other tough
stuff when it's needed being forthright
not concealing anything not being a
different person with your friend than
who you are off by yourself
the real friend this may seem a little
silly but the real friend is the person
with whom you can sort of take off the
mask so they get to see the real of you
maybe the real of you is a little
indecisive sometimes or it gets
depressed
can be [ __ ] occasionally over small
stuff or what else did what are helping
things that we do as weird habits you
know needs the needs the stuff on the
counter to be lined up just this way
you're not gonna you're probably not
gonna reveal that to everybody but your
real friends know that stuff about you
right so there's a side to honesty that
goes beyond just like you know telling
friends the hard truths that they need
to hear it's like showing who you really
are to them do we find that attractive
you like when people reveal that
prettier did you say that's too much
information weird quirks maybe it has to
get to this point before you actually
want to hear that kind of stuff so what
else we have honesty and generosity yeah
yeah that goes a little bit I mean you
can be honest with somebody but not be
loyal not be trustworthy not be what's
the word that we use when somebody you
can rely on them when they when they say
they're gonna do something they're gonna
do it
committed isn't is not quite the word we
want reliable somebody is reliable
that's that's a good character trait
that's a virtue that's a kind of
goodness in a person being unreliable
and you all know people who are
unreliable right they say they're gonna
pick you up at 5:00 they show up at 7:00
they don't just do it once in a while
this is something that they do all the
time that's a that's a vice that's a bad
character trait that's something that we
don't like
even people who are unreliable like
reliability in other people's right
because they there's something
inherently attractive about virtue
there's something inherently repugnant
or repulsive or irritating or disgusting
about vice what are other what are other
things yeah
okay yeah what do we call that being
self-sacrificing being altruistic that's
pretty important for friendship if you
only if you only do something when
you're going to get something company
you're still at this level right now
that you know you wouldn't do that with
everybody there's there's a lot of
people who won't appreciate what you do
if you sacrifice for them and maybe
there's some cases where it would be
imprudent to do that say what somebody
who's abusive with you what are they
going to use that against you but in
general that's a good trait what about
courage bravery you know somebody who
comes to your aid when you're being
attacked somebody who you would feel
safer with walking down the dark alley
or walking into a tense situation
that's that's a good trait isn't it
justice is another one that the ancients
valued quite highly being fair not
taking more than your your share the
kind of person that you don't have to
actually watch while they cut up the
cake to make sure they don't give you
the tiny piece and give themselves the
big piece or you know you could actually
lend your ATM card or your credit card -
that would be a measure in our society
of justice would you give your credit
card to somebody not to anybody you'd
never give you a credit card to anybody
what do we knew that they actually were
and they had all these traits
reliability
never still
okay we're getting to the point where
where they have these they have some
things you need to walk past it and I
suppose they could go on you know but
mostly you have to scan it inspect it
it's time to figure that but but in the
future maybe we'll have you know all
sorts of things we just accidentally use
it okay so a virtuous person has these
good character traits or at least with
the way Cicero describes it the good
person at least recognizes that they
ought to have these traits that if
they're missing them and to the degree
that they're missing them they're
falling short of the standards this is
something that's I think really central
to Cicero's vision here there are
certain standards and these standards
don't just depend on our feelings or
preferences or convenience these are
something objective outside of ourselves
and we measure ourselves and we measure
other people according to those
standards and their actions and their
choices and their motivations and some
people are going to fall short of those
standards when you have standards one of
the things that that involves is
actually saying some people are good
people and some people are bad people
some people measure up and other people
don't and you might actually be on the
wrong side of that fence you you know
it's common in our own experience even
for people who are you know eventually
virtuous to realize that they're not all
there that they have things to work out
so whereas Aristotle represented it's
sort of like you know friendships of
virtue are these people who are already
at the high peaks and they just sort of
recognize the virtue in each other and
they
attracted to each other because of that
Cicero's got a more realistic viewpoint
designating something I think it's
easier for you to relate to when you get
past all that
you know Roman verbiage and examples
it's easier I think for us to think of
ourselves as people that are on the way
to or at least recognising the need for
this sort of thing and what this would
make possible for us in friendships so
there's a few other things that Cicero
actually says about it about virtue that
I think would be good to mention here he
talks about a virtuous person having a
constancy of character some people don't
have constancy there they're different
in each situation so you know we often
call them two-faced or you say that you
don't really know who they are because
they don't have the same they don't
approach different situations in the
same way but it's not just about
situations it's also over time somebody
who you could be really good friends
with they have to be the kind of person
that is going to remain the same over
time they're fairly fixed that means
that they have to have something sorted
out I mean think about it at your age
what are what are some of the things as
college students entering college
students that you're kind of sorting out
about your own desires your own
interests your own loves and hates yeah
well that's a big one right how many of
you figured out what your major is so
far how many of you haven't yet now of
those of you who have figured it out how
many of you could see yourself doing
something else as well a few that's a
big one figuring out what you're going
to do with your life right if you go one
direction that may be a very different
lifestyle than going in a different
direction
it won't be just a matter of studying
different things it'll be a matter of
making different choices doing
things day in day out you know yeah that
could affect who we need to be friends
with all right you know you you could
potentially go in in directions that
would cut you off from people who you
were friends with because you'd no
longer have anything really in common
not just with your your interest like in
music or things yeah that may actually
stay the same but your basic drives the
values that you recognize what else are
you trying to sort out at this point in
your life yeah and sleep there's that
that they call it the college triangle
social life academic performance and
sleep you can't actually satisfy all
three demands at once in a really good
way it's you do have to find something
with the column oh the workplace they
call this work-life balance right here
in college is more about studying and
social life I think all the work is
going to enter into it because you guys
are going to do internships and start
making connections and some of you are
going to hold jobs what else what else
are your sorting out what else don't
give completely figuring out at this
point do you know what your type is for
who you ought to be dating have you got
that completely figured out do they do
is just you know get onto match.com and
look for people like that you'll be
perfect do you have it figure it out
sometimes it takes people decades to
figure out who is actually good for them
and who they're actually attracted to
people get into relationships because
they think I'm really attracted to this
over here that this person has and then
you know a couple weeks later they're
like yeah this is not making me happy at
all part of what's going on with your
life
you have to figure that out through
trial and error to some degree yeah Nate
a few people see what you actually do
like what you don't like go through
difficult breakups that's gonna affect
you know that's gonna affect the way in
which you can carry out a friendship you
know if you want to have stability you
have to have that sort of thing at least
more or less sorted out you want to be
in a committed relationship or you want
to just date a lot of people that's a
big the important decision isn't it
yeah maybe at this point you're like you
want to date a lot of people because
you're in college and you know got away
from all the high school people and now
you can actually have fun and play the
field but that me night after you get
out of college maybe you want to have a
committed relationship you would have to
have these things figured out to have
stability and we could run through a lot
of a lot of other things as well so
that's important the the virtuous person
Cicero says rightly loves themself they
we all love ourselves sister oh thanks
but do we love ourselves for the right
reasons what are what are reasons people
think highly of themselves that might be
more
their parents money a perfect example
I suppose that's probably an issue here
at Marist right it hasn't been an issue
it's mostly suspect by where everybody
was poor or in prison although well
there are the right guys in prison who
are like dad better than all these other
guys I'm not like these guys yeah
Aristotle talked about that in terms of
like high birth right but but yeah
riches well having money just makes you
have money doesn't make you a good
person
matter of fact it makes objective more
temptations okay what else what are
other experienced reasons people place
themselves on a pedestal yeah yeah if
people who are attractive there's
actually this great comedy routine I
think it's in I think it's in college
humor there's this girl and she's very
pretty
yeah she was like walking around and of
course everybody's doing things for her
right because cuz you know if you're
attractive people like to have you
around they do things for you and give
you freebies and so her life is totally
insulated from what normal people's
lives are like and she's talking about
this and then you know where does the
humor come in she thinks this is reality
and of course it's not she's everybody
who's like bending over backwards to do
things work now you know a lot of
good-looking people think that they're
better than other people
conversely people who are not you know
particularly good-looking may think less
of themselves and they deserve to
because you know the body's very
ephemeral looks can change overnight you
know your soul is something a bit more
lasting what else money looks yeah yeah
people people value themselves they
think now that I've become a member of
this group I've made it out of somebody
who matters I think I suppose you argue
that group and people who think that
that's important but it doesn't
necessarily make make a good person
doesn't provide you with this the
virtuous person good the virtuous person
is the only person who actually thinks
highly of themselves for the right
reasons I don't even think about talents
- you know you're smart most of you are
pretty smart otherwise you wouldn't be
hearing merits you have hide SAT scores
that's something you could actually feel
legitimate pride in you can feel more
legitimate pride if you're actually
doing something with your great
intelligence rather than just sort of
you know passively imbibing things very
actively developing it that's a kind of
urgent cicero's not talking so much
about that that's what we call the
intellectual virtue and that takes
development so
that's important the virtuous person
also knows virtue and other people they
can recognize that people who are bad
people often can't recognize the
goodness in other people there's a sort
of moral whine because that goes with
that now
what is what is friendship due to this
this stuff over here is it just the case
that you know you've got two virtuous
people and they like look at each other
from across the room and you know one
can see the other ones shining virtue
that's in them and now they get together
and everything's great after that or
does virtue develop within bad ships
this is virtue only really become what
it can fully be within friendships what
is this
aerosol is it sounds an awful lot like
the first doesn't it plus let's actually
look at what Cicero says he says that in
in friendship virtue is a helper
friendship is a helper the virtues
greater heights of virtue can be reached
in a friendship than when you're on your
own so there's some things in order to
actually actualize to make real kinds of
goodness you need other people to do
that I mean this is not quite at the
level that he's talking about the thing
about a sports team can you play some
games on your own what are examples of
things that you can do out here we could
run a race right you don't need those
other runners on your team to be there
when you're coming out of the blocks it
probably doesn't make much difference at
all I know it didn't for me when I ran
at rest I didn't care who I was next to
now what about a game like soccer or
football or volleyball or lacrosse can
you do that on your own it's not really
the game isn't I mean you could you
could take a football to run around the
yard with that you're not playing
football right or you could get a soccer
ball if you could juggle it you know
kick it in the air that's not yet soccer
it would be like that for lacrosse I
don't really know lacrosse but I know
it's bigger up here I guess just having
the ball and then what's the stink hole
it's our name for it there's just the
stick okay flipping it your even if
you're throwing it at the goal you're
not yet playing across in order to do
well with it you need other people right
you need you need other people on your
team and you actually need other people
play against now are there things like
that in life so snow doesn't talk about
this much but what about producing a
family if producing a family is a good
thing to all of you want to someday have
a family you think family is kind of a
good thing you like your own family more
or less what do you need can you just go
out and purchase one purchase a family
for yourself some people do weird stuff
like that but
what's up nomads setup your breath
button Angelenos just about yeah but
notice there's two of them right do you
have to have at least two people
involved for it to be a family that it's
a generational thing you know the notion
that one person would just go out like
adopt you know a million kids and
they're a family there's something a
little bit weird about that something
walkabout that I know there's nothing
wrong with adoption you know that's
that's actually a great thing I think
I'm adopted myself and I'm very happy
that has adopted into the family that I
was adopted in a family I would
turned out very well for me but if you
want to have a family you actually need
to have people getting together don't
you it's not something you can do all by
yourself if there is virtue in that if
there's virtues that can be exercised in
that those are virtues that can only be
exercised within that by kind of teaming
up that caring maybe there's things like
that for me being friends with somebody
else out there not a romantic
relationship but but something else
maybe there's there's virtues that we
can only fully develop within the
context of friendship that's what Cicero
seems to be saying what else is going on
in in friendship with with virtue he
says that virtue helps to sort of fill
in the gaps if I'm virtuous at least to
some extent and here you know on your
way to virtue what I can provide makes
up for what what you're not yet
providing so he's got this beautiful
phrase where he says that the absence or
presence in friendship the absence are
are present those who are not there are
able to be there when you're thinking
about your friend you're reflecting on
them you're making them presence in your
heart the poor are rich if you know if
you if you're in a relationship and it's
primarily based on virtue not just on
getting something out of the rich person
the rich person is happy to help out the
porter person they're happy to - you
know he paid for dinner each time or to
help sort out their financial situation
because the friendship isn't just about
that sort of thing or he says the weak
are strong think about all the different
ways in which we can be weak all the
different times when we need the help of
our friends for example romantic
relationships again have you ever had to
break up with somebody that you really
need to break up with but it was hard to
break up with them
because you felt the ad about breaking
up with them or you wanted to break up
with them because you recognized they
were bad for you but there were also
some very attractive qualities about
them that you weren't quite yet ready to
give up on maybe you had a friend who
was supporting you during them and
saying you've got to stick with this you
have to break up with them that would be
the strong or the weak becoming strong
through what you know friendship allows
he even says the dead are alive
that's a striking idea particularly
given that you know who are the main
characters of this
it's this guy Laelius wine is Laelius
telling his friends about friendship his
sons applause actually fam family
members because his best friend has just
died Scipio under really weird
circumstances by the way historically at
the sort of the height of his political
career
Scipio got messed up and they got mixed
up with the wrong crowd they actually
think he was he might have been killed
by his own in-laws the Gracchi he's
opposing so the dead are are present to
us in friendship friendship provides a
unique location or locus for generosity
you know we you can be generous to other
people right you can be generous to your
fellow classmates if you want to if any
you want to bring in a snack one day I
mean I mean okay with that down any of
you will but you know if you wanted to
but I wouldn't you know restrict that
because it's a nice thing to do isn't it
but within friendship we have a lot more
occasion for displaying generosity
towards each other don't we day after
day after day are we doing family as
well but friendship it's based on
goodwill to the other person this role
talks about an honorable rivalry between
the friends each each one if they really
have virtues if they're not just trying
to get something out of each other they
really you know like each other because
of the kind of people they are they go
out of their way to try to do
for each other he also talks about sort
of a sharing but what he calls a
community toss and it's not only about
plans what we want to do or about things
or affairs like you know having property
in common being on the same team
he says it's of wills and here he's
introducing a term that is going to be
very important later on from the people
like Augustine what is your will we say
your will I don't mean like you know
when you die you know your money's gonna
go here or here here I mean the will
that's inside of you your Faculty of
will what does that do
you have a free will
but you do what's what's free about it
exactly your your Willis is the part of
you that chooses it's not just the part
of you that feels or thinks there's a
part of you that makes choices that's
what we call the willful Voland time
rule in laughs and in Augustine this
turns out to be very important as well
see and Cicero it doesn't have quite the
same you know meaning and connection but
it has some role he and friends who are
friends in terms of virtue they share in
each other's wills there's a community
of will my choices and your choices
would be as we say on the same page
directed towards the same objects this
could even affect the friendship itself
my will is to be friends with you
your will reciprocally is to be friends
with me we have the same will in that
respect we're valuing the same thing
friendship he also talks about bringing
the higher down to the lower this is
again I don't think you see this quite
so much in Aristotle the higher it comes
down to the lower and doesn't treat the
lower it has lower with air to stop when
you have those unequal friendships it
was very clear that the person on the
bottom they had better realize how lucky
they are to be in a friendship with
somebody who's this high up and they'd
better be providing something like honor
or respects or you know affection to
that person to make up for the fact that
they have nothing to offer them other
than you know just honor or respect love
they don't have any wealth they don't
have any virtue cicero sees it
differently doesn't he he thinks that in
if you really are a virtuous you bring
yourself down not by you know becoming
bad or anything like that but you bring
yourself down to the level of the other
person you don't make them feel like
they are not
partner now contributing there's
something very attractive about that
isn't there that that would be part of a
virtue friendship also like he says
involves adapting yourself to other
people those who are really friends with
each other he says will adapt themselves
as much as it's fitting to the feelings
and the will of the other person he says
virtuous tender and flexible in
friendship it's not hard and repellant
so this is a good place now to shift
topics as you notice I said as much as
it's fitting as much as is allowable are
the things that friends ask of us that
we shouldn't do or that sometimes we ask
of friends simple answers yeah that's
right
what are they oh that's
all right landing you know I remember
when I was in the army a very different
era in the barracks of a lot of guys who
are hardcore alcoholics and also big
gamblers - overseas you could gamble you
know as much as one it cuz you know most
state laws and invariably there would be
guys would like blow through a lot of
their money their paycheck early on and
they would want you to make them alone
and if you were unwilling to make them
alone they would then get very angry
with you why would they become angry
because they felt like you can owed it
to them to allow them to owed you money
money that you probably would never see
usually they'd ask you for it when they
were drunk already
you know they want to go back out to the
park maybe there's some people you
shouldn't lend money to maybe there's
times you shouldn't lend people money
what else yeah why yeah that's a big lie
or even just conceal or misrepresent
often times we want to date somebody we
want our friends to like cannot be on
their best behavior
don't let them know anything about the
real us then they probably wouldn't want
to date us make sure our friends say all
these great things about you never know
soup kitchen every week this is the
stuff romantic comedies or write a lot
of romantic comedies consistent the hero
and the heroine you know meeting up and
sparks fly and they think they're really
good people and then one of them finds
out the other one it's not as good of a
person and then they break up and then
you know after a while maybe the the
person actually does become a good
person now they find out about it and
now they're back together
that's a plot because you know it has to
do with real life stuff that's why we
find it so so interesting what else what
other things
what other things friends may have asked
you to do that you were very
uncomfortable with yeah I guess in there
we can also put like on the tree era
give me a you know give me a favor that
you don't give other people helped me
get this job that you know everybody's
will sent with even chance a hot I guess
I'd be kind of cheating to what else
yeah like a peer pressure with drinking
and stuff okay so let's say to do a dumb
things
oh you know a little drinking is
probably not bad yeah
drinking when you're 12 that's probably
bad
all right the reason I bring that up is
that you know I remember going on
camping trips and the older kids would
have stolen some liquor from their
parents and we'd drink it
just wanted to be cool right
what did would you dump things
but I suppose the limits there's like no
limits on them the sort of dumb things
that peer pressure can get you to do you
know dress in certain days say say
things in a certain way that's that's
kind of stupid that may even make you
stupid after a while if you talk that
way too long
forgo a lot of good opportunities you
know better yourself a lot of things
like that anything else come in mind
we had thanks
maybe some things are shameful for you
you know people will sometimes command
of their friends that they do things
that are humiliating for them then they
can feel devalued they say if you really
are my friend or you really love me
you'll do this one person says I'm not
comfortable with that well I understand
that you have to make this sacrifice
this one time
now Cicero says there could be some
things that they are uncomfortable with
that a friend requires you to do that
are actually good things like oh you
stole that you should go and turn it
back in and at least put it back on the
shop and maybe you should tell the store
they stolen but even if you don't do
that go go replace it and these I'm not
really comfortable with that well it'd
be a good thing for you to do you become
a better person by doing that but a lot
of things that their friends demand of
us where we get uncomfortable are our
bad things
let's go pick on that guy over there
bullying isn't a great example there are
all the people who are doing bullying at
any given time necessarily bullies or
even happy with what they're doing at
the time
mahtim actually a peer pressure can you
know be a part of it the pressures
brought to bear on that if I don't do it
they're gonna believe me instead it's
still a bad thing right if a friend asks
you to do something that's bad what does
Cicero say about this morally bad or
repugnant or disgusting
should you give in to them should you do
it they say a lot of people would say
yes if you're really friends with a
person you stick by them no matter what
like if I let's say we were all friends
we're from the same neighborhood we know
each other I commit a crime I asked you
to help me let's that kill somebody help
you to help I asked you to help me cut
up the body and conceal it you think
that's a bad thing to do
I shouldn't have killed that person but
we're friends and this is a real
testament ship now it's like a chance
for you to step up and show me how to
mitad you are to me maybe you should do
it so sir would say not so sir would say
that when it comes to virtue a virtuous
person is not going to behave in such a
way it has to place those kind of
demands on friends and when friends
place those kind of demands it's not
being virtuous to give in to them it's
actually making you a worse person it's
showing that the friendship is not quite
what you thought it was where is the
friend quite what you thought and
there's there's a kind of an interesting
paradoxical structure here a lot of
times people will do what the friend
asks them to do even though they feel
that it's wrong in their heart and then
how do they feel about it afterwards
they they know that the action was wrong
how do they feel about the friendship
afterwards and the prep
they say I'm so glad I did that now
we're so close
do they feel closer to the friend who
required something to add of them that
they at least still recommend is bad
then they feel betrayed certainly put
upon devalue and you know an interesting
example of this is when in a romantic
relationship
one partner wants to not get you know
not get very hot and heavy right away
and the other partner says well you know
don't you aren't you attracted to me
don't you love me let's let's you know
get entangled right away euphemism my
grandpa used to use didn't realize how
hot he was talking about sex until I
figured I might get an ankle because we
have lots of stories where people were
you know interestingly enough quite
promiscuous at least of the places he
went to so one partner says to the other
I don't I don't want to do that right
now I might want to later man this
partner says if you really value the
relationship you will do this so they do
it how does it how does this person over
here feel about the relationship
afterwards
sometimes it switches to hatred or
disgust the relationship itself loses
its value and I've been doing that so
this leads us to what Cicero was calling
constraints that is one of the the
central good constraints that you could
place on friendship friends shouldn't
constraints or
through the better word we use this word
these days that way boundaries in turn
even say limits so much we say
boundaries a person has boundaries if
you're in a friendship you should have
certain boundaries those boundaries
should have to do with moral right
you're wrong not so much of other things
should you have boundaries about how
much you're willing to sacrifice for
your friends if it's not something
morally right or wrong probably not if
you're really friends with that you
should be willing to go to the wire go
to any extreme but if they ask you to do
something that's clearly wrong
dishonorable to you as a result then you
shouldn't go along with that sister
ourselves that's that's a hard and fast
women
another thing that's this introduces is
that we shouldn't make friends too
quickly we shouldn't say that people are
our friends in the full sense and think
that we have to be committed to them in
the same way as we are to our complete
you know good friends we shouldn't do
that as indiscriminately we do them well
my kids are a great example I remember
my you know daughter being at a
playground she just got a kid like you
know two minutes ago she said I want to
introduce me to my new friend I was like
that's not your friend yet just you know
playing together on the playground
doesn't make you friends we don't know
anything about this guy at this point so
be careful about that and we do this in
many other words we think of working on
the same institution where we grew up
with each other or you know we've known
each other for a while that we're all
friends we have a Facebook connection
maybe not maybe you know it takes a
while to get to know somebody so we
should be careful about who we open
ourselves up to
let's say what are other constraints
that people put on a friendship he talks
about a bunch of mistaken points of view
and you know typical Roman
attributes' these to the Greeks those
hooded people over there who are
corrupting our culture he says that some
people think that you should avoid close
friendships altogether why well because
you know close friendships they make a
lot of demands on you and you know if
you want to have a nice easy life it's
better not to have any close friendships
what do you guys think of that I don't
sister oh thanks what do you guys think
is that does it make sense is that a
good idea
yeah
now how do you know that how did you
personally exactly if now if you begin
by saying I don't want to get attached
to anybody and you actually fall through
it you'll never have the kind of
experience that you have had were you to
know there's there's something valuable
here you have to actually put yourself
out there and let me get hurt in the
process
some people are not gonna be a very good
guys but if you if you do experience
something like what Cicero was talking
about then you realize that's that's a
bad way to live it's you know to try to
be totally on your own there's something
lacking to that the other Greek idea
then he talks about he says friendships
are only to be saw it on account of the
protection and help they provide not
because of goodwill in a fashion so that
seem to be something missing to that as
well and in Cicero says part of what we
actually like about friendship is not
just getting nice things from the friend
it's the very feeling that feeling of
love between us and the friend we like
feeling long towards the front we like
feeling that we're loved by the friend
so that would mean giving that up let's
say we put those aside if you talked
about three other miss
views about how we ought to set down
boundaries or limits so one of these is
that persons should be willing to do for
a friend only what that person would be
willing to do for him or herself like
that makes a lot of sense
you know first blush doesn't it think
about they all do onto others as you
would have them do out to you
commandant that's sort of along the same
lines you could say well yeah I don't
care if people like you know literate my
yard so I can litter in other people's
yards because I'm happy with what I'm
doing out to me the same way that I do
not to them that's what I'm worried
about that particular problem he says
that doesn't work because there's some
things that you should do for a friend
that would be silly or kind of shameful
for you to do for yourself that's an
interesting idea what would be some
examples of that when I was talking
about with my wife on the road downtown
I said you know buying yourself cards
and then leaving them for yourself I bet
there's somebody doing no not any of you
in this class but there's probably
somebody who does that that's weird
or something kind of strange about that
love you so much and happy that we're
friends putting in a net and wall stick
it maybe in like my dossier now is it
normal to do that for friends sure or
think about this in terms of Facebook
should you click like on your own posts
or is that tacky do you know any people
who click like on their own post what do
you think about it doesn't look rise to
the level like moral turpitude right but
but it's you know there's something off
about that now should you do it for your
friends
gotcha makes your Facebook friends that
that thumbs up button right there's a
lot of things like that
another mistake in position reduces
friendship to just a sort of exchange it
says what a person does for his or her
friend should be roughly equal to what
the friend provides for him or her now
if you start looking at your friendships
in this way you are going to slide down
the scale from friendships of virtue
into friendships of usefulness aren't
you and you're gonna start to value the
friend no longer for their own sake even
though you might have started out there
and you're gonna start valuing them just
for what you can get out of them and if
they don't provide you with what you
think you ought to deserve from them
you're gonna get mad at them and and
they'll lead to problems the third one
that he talks about is really
interesting one want to value the friend
at the same level of the friend values
him or herself so if I have a certain
self literally call this if I have a
certain level of self evaluating self
esteem we call this sometimes self
assessment whatever I assess myself as
if you're my friend you want to treat me
that way
now what problem would you see
immediately right arising with that yeah
about yourself no one's there friends to
agree with them
yeah interestingly that's getting to
what sister was talking abut you're
turning it in a different way when
you're depressed you don't want your
friends they actually say oh you're
depressed yeah well you are has come
back you know you're not worthy of
anything you want your friends to
actually like lift you up a bit and
console you this what says of you you
should watch out for friends who are
depressed because if you had this sort
of mentality you would treat them like
they're crap but when you're depressed
you feel like crap right it's part of
what it means it's not a medical
diagnosis but it's in the vernacular but
that's what it that's what depression is
like what would be the other problem
with it that Cicero doesn't talk about
let's say I think more highly of myself
than I actually deserve should you
really treat me like I should you should
you treat me according to my own self
assessment if I'm not a virtuous person
if I'm kind of deluded about my own
value if I think for example because I'm
rich I'm I'm very important yeah what
were the other things you rich
good-looking in fact if I think because
I'm good-looking that I should get the
best places in the restaurant and you
should like you know I should be the
first person on here to do that stuff
because I'm good-looking now if you
followed that rule then you know you
would say oh of course that's how
husband they came towards you but isn't
that a little crazy so we don't want to
treat friends that have too low
self-esteem according to their views of
themselves we also don't want to treat
the ones that have too high self esteem
unduly high songs
we want to treat them according to their
their merits one of the other things
that Cicero does to a cadet and I want
to get this in before we we animals is
breakups
whoever it is they compete last time
takes precedence over nonsense calls
breakups why why do people break up why
did friendships break up there's there's
more than one reason right and it's not
always a bad thing sometimes you
actually should break off the friendship
so there's really two things Cicero
talks about why friendships break up and
how you ought to break up so what are
what are some of the reasons why
friendships break up well you know it
could be that one friend makes a demand
on another that they shouldn't make and
the other friend says that he had it
with you for you
once I did one keeps giving
yeah that'll there's a lot of issues
that arise in friendship when one friend
feels slighted by the other one it's not
just you know somebody making demands
and saying you have to cover up the body
for me or you know we need to have sex
right now or else we're not friends or
you need to lend me money it's things
like how come you never actually buy a
round of drinks what the hell's wrong
with you or I go to you know I listen to
your BS and you have
boyfriend-girlfriend problems why don't
you listen to mine that's part of it
part of it is is you know the aging
process
Cicero thinks that you guys right now at
the age that you're currently living in
you are in flux your desires are
changing you are you are figuring out
what you're really interested in like
your majors for example and what kind of
trajectory of life you want have yeah
whether you want to date or whether you
don't want to date who you know what
kind of people you want to date what you
know what kind of priorities you have in
your life is staying fit and eating
healthy a priority or is enjoying
yourself as much as possible a priority
those things are gonna change over time
you know you should not be the same
person coming out of Marist when you
graduate less than 4 years from now then
the person you are when you first came
in as a matter of fact none of you are
probably even the same person in some
respects halfway through the first
semester that you were when you first
came in willing to bet that if you can
do some introspection you can identify
ways in which you've changed so what's
going to happen if you have a friendship
with somebody from your childhood and
you go this way man go this way the
friendship is going to dissolve right
what are other things that could make us
fall on friendship
this one talks about rivalry competition
he talks about you know competing for
political office not that big of a deal
for us and you can be a class president
or club president I suppose they could
bring a franchise what a we usually
compete over more often than our society
status right
what else yeah
that could definitely put down some
problems yeah now in what sense it was
more than one right yeah they give you
two friends both are interested in
seeing
romantically yeah yeah Cicero talks
about that in terms of competition over
wives he means like marrying people who
have money but I think in our time we
would see romantic competition zone that
breaks up friendships doesn't what's up
a person's attention yeah it could be
not even like romantic relationships but
you and I are friends with the same
person and we both want that first
especially time with us and you know our
competition over that causes you and I
to become rivals at least or perhaps
enemies and know what Cicero talks about
he thinks it's very important to avoid
replacing friendship with hatred it's
very easy to do that though isn't it
we're not careful he has two different
suggestions one is that well you could
just you know sort of break off a
friendship in a respectful way that
needs to be broken off no bitterness no
name-calling just you know I'll say okay
it's yours where it ends and that's
really like let's sing that sitting down
some boundaries is them the other thing
he advises which is kind of interesting
he says Caden was supposed to be this
wise man who talked about unlacing
friendships unlacing the cords of
friendships rather than cutting them
what does he mean by that he means well
you know if you if you don't spend time
with somebody if you if you sort of
disassociate from them after a while
your feelings and your thoughts about
each other they're just gonna kind of
fade away and you're gonna cease to be
friends but you're not going to become
enemies you're just going to become like
you know acquaintances or even strangers
to each other
and he thinks that's a better idea than
arousing empathy it's very easy to break
up two people by saying look you're a
jerk I hate you get away from me he
thinks we should have waited that sort
of thing so we'll we'll close on that
bit of advice and then we drop to close
with Cicero